Ukrainian forces have broken through
Russian defenses in the south of the
country while expanding their rapid
offensive in the East they're seizing
back more territory in areas annexed by
Russia and threatening supply lines for
Putin's troops officials there installed
by Moscow have acknowledged Ukraine's
advances in the kherson region one of
four that Russia illegally annexed last
week Ukrainian troops are said to have
gained territory as much as 30
kilometers away from where the front
stood just days ago
from the regions of hakive in the North
to her son in the south
the Ukrainian flag is being raised in
villages across the country's East once
again
as Keys counter-offensive continues to
push forward
today the offensive movement of our army
and all our Defenders continued there
are new liberated settlements in several
regions Fierce fighting continues in
many areas of the front
but beyond the victory the cost of War
emerges
here in liman recaptured by Ukraine at
the weekend
bodies of Russian Fighters
line the streets
Ukrainian soldiers must also collect the
bodies of their own
we fight for our land for our children
so that people can live better but all
this comes at a very high price
residents like 85 year old Valentina
struggle with what little they have
the Russians may have been forced out
but life here remains grueling
equality and for our children and
families to be alive and healthy
in towns like liman
things are far from normal
but there are moments to pause and
reflect
on what the success means for their
future
well for more let's bring in Justin
Crump he's an intelligence and security
expert and CEO of the intelligence
consultancy civil line he joins us
tonight from the UK Mr crumb welcome to
the day Ukraine has long been working on
the Hearthstone front why do you think
they managed to break through now
it's the offensive there by Ukraine I
think when it started in September we
characterized it as slow steady and
likely to be successful I mean we've
certainly talked about it on this
program before
um there were some assumptions a few
weeks ago I think when the offensive
started in harcive that the push and
Herson was a faint just designed to draw
off the Russians we always saw it as a
more substantial threat to the Russians
than that and it's just been a different
type of operation though
um a lot of the time has been about
preparing the ground the Russians have
that problem in Hearthstone that they're
on the wrong side of the nepro river and
that's made their supply chains very
vulnerable they've been able to build up
some supplies on that bank of the river
Ukraine destroyed those a few nights ago
they're targeted whether supplies are
being built up and they hit those and
that seems to have been the key act that
opened up this stage the offensive so
then what they've actually then done is
go through the Russian front line they
found weak points uh in the Russian line
they've ground down the Russian troops
so it never rotated
um they didn't get breaks they don't
reconstitute their formations they just
leave people in place and strongholds so
Villages and wood blocks and things
um and eventually of course the Russians
would just ground down to the point that
the ukrainians could punch through their
lines and once they've gone through
those lines it made it untenable for the
Russians to carry on holding the
northern section of that front hence
they've Fallen back as far as they have
in the last two days how is Russia
likely to respond what are they even
capable of at this point
you know that second part of the
question is is quite important I think
because what are their capabilities I
mean what was on the front lines was
spread very thin
um is very worn down um they had quite a
lot of older equipment in that area
which was odd because it was the area
that was meant to have been the most
reinforced but certainly some of the
older tanks they took out of storage
um were active in that area which I
think surprised some observers
um they believe they're gonna be held
more in reserve so I think it shows how
spread thin the Russians were and how
much they were relying on this very
static Warfare defending Villages and
using artillery
um to hold the line because eventually
when you get worn down enough you can't
do that anymore when you have ammunition
Logistics shortages so really at this
point I mean they are pulling back
because they don't have a lot of other
choices they'll be trying to consolidate
another defensive line they'll be trying
to get supplies up and they'll be trying
to
um take advantage of the fact it's a
shorter front line to be able to have a
higher troop density on that line but
they're in a pretty precarious situation
I think both there and at the far East
and end of the line as well well at the
moment so for the Russians it really is
just trying to hold on with everything
they've got what they mobilize and try
and bring more to the fight let's talk
about that troop density and more people
being brought to the fight the Russian
government says it has so far called up
200 000 reservists can these troops
realistically be deployed to Ukraine in
a way that would make a difference
what's made the Ukrainian forces
affected that they've used these two
offensives was the fact they took time
to build up the forces to train them and
altogether make them better than some of
their parts they use deleted equipment
they use the training they're getting in
the UK and other nations to create
effective forces that could work
together very very well coordinated well
well LED and they're able to achieve
much more than their numbers dictate
Russia's the other way around they've
got lots of people they are poorly
trained at best they're extremely badly
motivated as we've seen they're
suffering from corruption affecting
equipment supplies Food Supplies they
can't maintain the people they've got at
the moment in the field and really their
system just isn't working for them it
has so many structural problems
um that these guys are going to be a lot
less effective than their numbers
dictate that said you know obviously 200
000 more people
um on the ground that's the size of
force that Russia deployed at the start
of the conflict it is going to make life
more difficult for the ukrainians of
course eventually over a time and that's
why it's so important for them that
they're Gathering ground now they're
hitting the Russians while they're weak
and before reinforcements have come in
in an effective manner although I don't
think the Russians will ever take the
time to build up their forces the way
they should they're in too much of a
panic to get troops to the front line so
how long do you think Ukraine can keep
up this momentum that they seem to be
having
it's a good question I mean obviously
they're very motivated by National
Defense so I mean morale is kept high in
that they're they've got a higher moral
they're winning they've got continued
support from Western Nations and the US
uh they've been able to hold on to that
now since since February and that's
Supply is constantly improving
um they're making good use of what
they're getting in effectively although
they're taking losses of course in
combat I think Ukrainian armed forces
are actually getting stronger every day
and you see that even in the air where
their Air Force is more active than it
was um it's still become increasingly
active through the conflict and of
course Russia would like to see it go
the other way so um you know they've
been able to do that so as long as those
conditions remain the same and they can
stay in the fight you know I think
through the winter into next year and
they've been fighting since 2014 so for
them as long as they have that support
they'll stay in the fight
um if that support breaks then that is
Putin's objective at the moment then
Ukraine obviously is going to be left in
the more precarious situation yeah as a
possible Game Changer Vladimir Putin has
been threatening the use of nuclear
weapons and we've seen reports of a
train operated by Russian military
nuclear division supposedly headed to
Ukraine how big do you consider the
threat of nuclear weapons being used on
the battlefield at this point
I mean it's it's a realistic threat but
I think it's one we shouldn't over
exaggerate I mean obviously there's a
huge amount of concern about it to take
the train story for example
um that got blown rapidly out of
proportion in the last 24 hours or so
um ditto the Russian submarines that see
Bell Grove their latest submarine and
see all of that together I think you've
got over exaggerated because people are
of course very very concerned about
nuclear warfare as I think we were
probably any sensible person would be
right so
um and that's part of what Putin's
trying to achieve though I think by
making more noise about nuclear
capabilities
um you know it is it is a realistic
Prospect for Russia to use them but not
one I think that we should be so
immediately scared of that it forces us
to accept their lines I think the
signaling is one of desperation at this
point Advantage with the use of those
weapons half for Russia though or would
the losses outweigh the gains really
I think the loss of face you know
credibility it's a real gamble it's
their end State thing to use uh is a
weapon like this it's we call them
tactical weapons to be used in the
battlefield but the reality is any
nuclear weapon is strategic because of
its effect
um and so using it somewhere within
Ukraine we'd anticipate probably not a
city because that's a very big stretch
but if they use them on the front line
somewhere against the military Target
um it really does escalate this to the
highest levels where
um effectively it could either be
suicide for us or maybe it's their last
gamble at Victory that they scare us so
much by showing their resolve to use
weapons that we crumble we stop
supporting Ukraine we make peace at any
cost but that is giving into aggression
of course and I think it's a dangerous
moment for us to look like we would
accept that so that's the big play
that's happening in the background here
so keep monitoring it you know I'm not
losing sleep over it yet I think it's
still a lot of noise about it
um and not enough to be you know
desperately concerned about this stage
because it is the last thing Russia
channel will do or really wants to do
but they'll certainly continue to make
noise of them Justin Crump military
analyst and CEO of cyberline thank you
so much for your time
thank you
and I'd like to take a closer look now
at the nuclear threat with Elena sokova
she's the executive director of the
Vienna Center for disarmament and
non-proliferation in the Austrian
Capital welcome back Miss okova at how
close are we to a nuclear escalation of
this conflict
I would probably agree with our previous
speaker that we're still far away from
the escalation to the nuclear level at
the moment
um and uh but I would also agree that we
should be not take it lightly and and be
prepared and take it serious
uh it's not uh zero and I don't think
it's something that we should be
considering that coming very soon so
today's
um kind of discussions in heightened
alert about these trains exactly is
creating a situation where we could
probably misjudge or misinterpret
certain moves but
um I think that
in reality what Russia has been
um channeling it Kremlin had been saying
Putin lately is all about the threat of
uh nuclear retaliation if the U.S or
NATO gets involved directly in the
military operations in Ukraine
and we've heard that luckily we have
a President Biden in the U.S who has
been very cautious and very
um uh clear about that the U.S would not
want to get engaged in the direct
military confrontation with Russia what
the U.S hasn't been too clear about is
about what its response would be to the
use of nuclear weapons by Russia and
that is something that Ukraine has
vociferously been complaining about I'd
like to play you something the former
head of the CIA David Petraeus said
today about the potential U.S response
and then get your opinion on it here it
is
that said again there's a number of
responses the one that I pointed out as
a possibility and it's only a
possibility a hypothetical would be that
this would be where the U.S and
presumably other countries whether it
would be NATO or Collective it's hard to
say uh could take action within Ukraine
perhaps in a way that would actually
make Russia's situation even worse in
other words to take out with
conventional forces
many of the Russian capabilities that
still exist in Ukraine and perhaps even
on the Black Sea
Ms sokova it's necessary of course to
point out that Mr petrios is not a
representative of the U.S government
anymore but how do you feel about this
kind of rhetoric being used Not For the
First Time by him
well I would agree first of all I'm glad
he's not in the U.S government and the
U.S military anymore I think it's a
dangerous rhetoric this is
um exactly the scenario that
um General Petraeus is suggesting that
would lead to the escalation if the U.S
attacks will be conventional forces
Russian Fleet As He suggests and other
major forces in Ukraine and possibly
even of the Russian territory this is a
direct way to get Russia's response and
if not in immediate nuclear response by
the possibility of it escalating to a
nuclear response this is something that
is
actually put in is channeling uh to with
his signals is that not to have that
direct engagement and it is one of the
scenarios in the Russian nuclear
Doctrine where it prescribes if there is
a large-scale conventional attack when
it which threatens their Russian
um State survival then the nuclear
response would be imminent and we don't
want to gamble on that so in this case I
think that this is not something that
should be
discussed and what proposed uh obviously
there would be heads that an individuals
who propose it but I think it's Reckless
and irresponsible the German foreign
minister says Russia's threat of nuclear
weapons used should be taken seriously
but that the International Community
shouldn't be daunted that's quite the
tightrope act there isn't it in your
opinion how is the West so far handling
the situation and this threat on the
table
um I as I said earlier first of all I
think that
um I would agree very much with the
approach that the U.S Administration
current Administration took in its
signaling to Russia first taking this
threat seriously but at the same time
signaling uh its resolved not to get
involved in response to it and using
other means from what we've heard that
there are
um discussions there are conversations
with the Russian leadership and
signaling that this would be
irresponsible but also if you think
about it if Russia were to use even the
smallest yield nuclear weapons for
whatever purposes in Ukraine or even
outside of Ukraine that would change
quite a lot for Russia first of all even
those who have been if not
um supportive but at least neutral or
not getting involved in the China the
development world it would change
overnight the the attitude towards
Russia and the war in Ukraine and it
would really make Russia a pry so I
think that there are still many of these
um constraints that we still have and
that would
um
Russia also would consider seriously and
Putin before resorting to the use of
nuclear weapons
excuse me
um I want to zoom out of it because the
U.S isn't just worried about Russia it's
a bigger strategic headache really is
China should we be concerned that the
signals Washington is sending to Moscow
are also meant for consumption in
Beijing
or I'm sure they are meant for China as
well because Russia well the US has to
nowadays to deal with two both with
Russia and with China and I think that
is uh really uh put a lot of strain on
the ability to handle both
um this to adversaries but I would say
China is watching very closely both the
Russians moved and the the U.S response
to to to to both the threats and the
actions on the ground related to the war
in Ukraine Elena sokova of the Vienna
Center for disarmament and
non-proliferation always a pleasure
speaking to you
thank you for having me